bella tutti ragazzini dove sono video
sono fa vj e per la prima volta su è più
vista 122 episodi questo 123 non ho mai
fatto una collaborazione su è pv questa
roba finissima perché sono io mi sta
cambiando ragazzi siamo slap vincono
ospite surreal power e oggi vi
dimostreremo quanto siamo procurati
visti insieme perché sabato 1 e grosso è
che visse l'altro e pro sua peace boat
flip non ha funzionato girato sì però
non l'hanno vista ha funzionato
ok ragazzi a dal primo livello di
chiuderne su steel diamond che uno di
che io non sono
noi avrà in stile raimondi facessi
auguriamo il primo tentativo lo faccio
io ci vedrei molto faccio schifo questo
è l'unico che vincerò è un melo
scommetti attento sapevo cosa tema che
all'ultimo l'ultima l'utimo faccio
cagliare che vinco non vinco mai a
questa gara bellissimo da allora come si
fa xvi oggi è bravissimo il maestro
abbiamo in bravo
perfetto sono sopravvissuto agli arpioni
muoio per la caduta ma che fai tutto lui
tutto lui carico ha mai fatto partire
face sembravano ricorda mai usato come
scudo con scudo e funzionate non ha
funzionato
no no no no che culo sito toccate
toccano solo soletto che a te ma anche
come adesso adesso tocca a te poi su
perfetto bravo l'ansia lancio epico
slancio epico finito male l'abbiamo
vinto siamo bravi 0,1 per cento possible
è contrario e lari che tra l'altro è un
insieme tra un imposti vuole un spyphone
quindi che cosa cosa ho fatto perché nel
senso al the sun backflip picchiasse
minco così nome non ci credo non ci
credo ma che a causa amici è salito line
ha buttato giù se c'è un piatto
bellissimo con asma replay lissimo cos'è
successo guarda vico guardano challand
si lancia al lato viene qui poi lasciato
così in burro manco baywatch e faceva
certe cose che cos'è
bello insieme da veri che funziona
storia della coppia head of my love
questo devi cacciare i bambini e scemi
dal vecchietto così ci sta è schiacciata
ma no no ho detto come non devo usare
sulla fontana è la miss ha scrito
andiamo ad avere preso in derby ti
mangio tutto banco frigo a sta cosa
sparkle ormai fatto che devono guidare
per partita pagando c'è un braccio in
bocca come me ne sbatto voli titone
anche perché mi piace la carne al sangue
quando è che riferiscono come fattori
partita solo con che fisica
vai vai questi mi piacciono e androidi
surreal power sono leggendarie famiglia
di diventare green bonus l'ho preso
attenzione bellissimo che io ho un extra
ball vai così funzione doppio no rain
boxster che hanno rai fiction singer of
swing e pacifiche bellissimo prego
aspetta che vanno fatti con eddy perché
lui maestà beni come bravo bravissimo
preceduti e tosca è una bestia a cui ci
è impossibile schmidt renderli no mi sa
che devo usare le belle braccia per
prendere le cose che diceva proprio un
altro tentativo interessante o chiesta
non è male ai attenzione mi hai fatto
tanti anni qui a kakà facciata il dato
ha detto o fatto olimpiadi da piccolo
fenomeno a sei mesi ho fatto le
olimpiadi facevo la palla quindi tu sei
per i roxy non pensavo sta roba
no infatti tipo 2 nella mia vita come
l'hai preso ei no non ci credo non ci
credo
aspetta vito lasciare in questa short
sociale invece sono 222 cosima fase di
rientri di bello ti lanci una volta e
bob assofin immagini già la vittoria ai
a bellissimo questo lancio di aver
aiutato i telai toccate prendiamo
qua sappiamo tutti e due ok bello vai ma
ti serve mai non ti servono
sopravvalutate stai facendo una cosa
bella però perfetto bravo no no no cosa
sei a terapia a cosa si alla vita
la speranza però a spingerti così magari
da qualche parte perfetto nell'isola che
ha visto che c'era ciro in un tentativo
lo sento
ecco dopo la sera ho vinto con un lancio
con un l'argomento con un lancio si crea
nel nether ultimi già belli già
pubblicati e difficilissimo allora
guarda in realtà i 123
ok hard hard committee of ma come come
video per yard e rosso è presente in 62
sapevo se il samani icona ma guarda
senza mani senza niente mi sa
trasformare dritto quanto storto se sei
riuscita a paio di generazioni costi
imposti con a cazzo duro grande non ci
fossero crediamo vinto ma i fatti in
samani mai cento sto parlando in cielo
congratula con gli etnei the ultimate
non capita spesso di bonn si è preso
l'infarto se vuole il celibato run ma
sei scemo vista preso per il culo regola
non me l'ha fatto in un commento
dopo occasione ho fatto mi fai manco
vincere noi il parto strumento è stato
bravo è stato grande pollice in su per
questa l'incredibile proprio ifly
brother rapid anche visto calore
rilanciare nel mai domi adesso in poi so
che controllarlo tipo non ci credo
non me ne vado dove mi aspetto il vento
ne vado lasciateci lasciato la base
legamenti mai come brian anche se bianco
no cosa vuol dire ok lo voglio parlare
ha bisogno di me va bene così
al 38 altri botti cui potrò mondo viene
proposto il tuo però il botto fip davy
caso i fan le vie di morire a no di chi
non c'è la cosa è fare il botto fitto
prima che arrivi la cosa eccolo il botto
fit quello vero ma ci provo arrivare la
in testa no arriva se viene è la botta
al 45 gradi celle se la botta non rimane
in piedi capovolgi il mondo dietro la dc
non è possibile basta a cosa cosa ha
fatto surf ora sta succedendo bellissimo
water fondo alla bottiglia largo pensavo
fosse una roba in acqua
sì la piscina tieni nonno ubriacati
dalle pene lamborghini belen o meno
laveno e da quella 4 milioni
questo lavoro milioni a 4 milioni per
rifarci questa macchina non per rifarci
i capelli esatto
ma si muove sì che si muove lamborghini
sento proprio come se la stesse guidando
davvero
non trovare mai dopo il cazzo duro senza
dio è meglio di forza horizon credibile
la grafica è quella a tre persone che
cercano guardando a battlefield cioè po
compagnia di bagnare l'altro ho fatto io
toglierei a della quale faccio per un
tentativo di vivi e hai presente il
teorema di pitagora cioè intanto l'uci
tronca vari cordoba in cui non c'entra
un cazzo
sono vivo però è rande molto solo timi
che va bene vai con quel cazzo è vero la
vetta ai dicendomi tuoi come perché
nella vita però il cassetto in
terminator ta sparato dante provare
qualche come funziona due momenti non
superi anche justin bieber si occupa che
è sta roba
ok vietare ai spa di fare spazio con a
ruota incornarlo come se fossi incolla
replicò ha capito quali fare un cazzo di
hacker è infatti sono ancora senza mani
ne ho una attaccata a metà e sono bravo
ce la farò e in realtà valentissimo non
capisco perché ma solo un boss ce la
puoi fare
per ultimo ci crede la gamba david abili
casto un mondo non è piaciuta quel coso
il video che fa tutto presidente ed i
canali a caso si butta dentro la casa e
io sono raimi stile o guarda o anche la
presa ma l'ultima più o meno ci ho
provato ciò però rompi tavoli non è male
ragazzuoli spero che questo video di
happy diverso vi sia piaciuto anche
perché sono lì e abbiamo il master 4 noi
due non sono capaci a fare queste cose
incredibili anche perché la stanza non è
mia non so se ve ne siete accorti
comunque sia ragazzi spero che adesso
visto che devi sapere se vi ringrazio su
riparare partecipato a questo video
tanto anche il canale in descrizione
tra questi temi società recasi ma sento
che bisogna segmento e mi piace anche la
pace di cui condivido nell'astigiano
dove si adiri ci vediamo il prossimo
video ok gambe ragazzi